i have chased after kids who don't  believe that i am obi-wan kenobi  i'm like i am i am obi-wan kenobi  as they run away mommy it's not him at  all  i saw in somebody's eyes once i was  driving my kids to school  and i was at a stop sign and some like  this is the thing about la you get like  16 or 15 and a half year olds driving  cars  blue pastas at a stop sign and i thought  that was very dangerous because it was  and i pulled up i raced after him and my  daughter was like don't don't and i was  like i will i'm going to and i pulled up  beside him and i started raging at him  you idiot you [ __ ] idiot like my  daughters were going like that dad but i  saw in his eyes i saw the  that's [ __ ] obi-wan kenobi